we know is the ozo the most exciting
thing you've ever worked on definitely
yes I was telling my boss and my family
that I really feel this to be a special
project it's one of those situations
where you have a great product but at
the right time where the market is ready
to receive it and understand exactly how
you're innovating in a specific space
fantastic why do you feel it's the right
time why 2015 or 2016 well the right
time actually was not really driven by
us but his external factors facebook
bought okaloosa there was no plan that
that was happening and suddenly the
whole industry is turning towards we are
like the big thing the past six eight
months you see so many companies
investing significant money in the VR
space and creating this great momentum
we've been so lucky because we started
two years ago not knowing that this was
going to happen this way but delivering
the product at the right time
you